bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 cultures et toutes
les sommaire de ce mardi 5 février
comment se débarrasser de son chagrin à
chagrin pour le moins envahissant gêner
le moine et sophie forte s'empare de la
question dans un théâtre de boulevard à
découvrir à plaisir depuis le 1er
février le théâtre des arcades de bubry
au rythme des rencontres théâtrales de
la ville des classiques des comptes et
des rêves sont au programme un nouveau
festival a vu le jour à versailles
pendant deux jours curieux et passionnés
ont pu se plonger au coeur des langues
classiques et nous recevons aussi le ld4
le jeune groupe guyancourt toit sera sur
la scène de la batterie en fin de
semaine c'est une pièce écrite à quatre
mains
virginie lemoine et sophie forte où nous
raconte l'histoire de pauline quittée
par son mari un personnage étrange et
attachant débarque à laon dans sa vie le
chagrin et pauline c'est sophie porte
forte par l'umq est avec nous en plateau
bonjour efforts jours et ce chagrin et
très attachant oui très attachant
d'autant plus que nous avons choisi un
magnifique garçon pour l'incarner donc
on n'a pas vraiment envie de s'en
débarrasser en même temps il le faut
donc c'est un duel entre moi et moi et
lui on parle de chagrin mais c'est avant
tout une comédie
oui c'est une comédie sur le chagrin
voilà c'est s'est amplifiée d'autres
personnages qui entre dans la pièce qui
sont d'autres émotions c'est william
mesguich qui est des interprètes une
douzaine de personnages et d'émotion il
joue marie joue les filles il joue la
meilleure amie me joue aussi la colère
la peur l'espoir le quotidien qui
reprend ses droits enfin toutes ces
choses que l'on rencontre quand on vit
un chamboulement pareil puisque un
chagrin c'est d'un coup une espèce de
tsunami qui vous dévasté il faut savoir
nager surnager faire en sorte de le
surmonter
compliqué comment est-ce qu'on en vient
à écrire sur le chagrin pourquoi c'est
pas un sujet facile mais tellement
universel
oui alors disons que certaines
circonstances de la vie nous pousse
parfois à écrire parce que ça nous fait
du bien de nous libérer
du chagrin notamment il y avait ça au
départ et puis aussi le fait j'ai
travaillé avec virginie lemoine qui est
une amie de longue date qui est un
univers très surréaliste et cette pièce
c'est un peu comme quand on entre dans
l'univers d'alice au pays des merveilles
se passe beaucoup de choses dans ma tête
et le décor est un peu mou vent tout ça
et c'est assez loufoque et c'était
intéressant de travailler un sujet grave
comme ça de façon aussi imprévisible je
dirais je propose concernant extraits
avant d'en dire un peu plus merci va je
ne devais points ce voyage tu arrivé
pendant des années et qu'on ne le fait
elle cet été ont en partie on va y aller
ensemble elles et moi
[Rires]
personnes rêvent de temps encore jours
[Musique]
est ce qu'il ya un peu de vous dans
cette pièce où vous êtes inspiré de
votre entourage qui sait peut-être un
jour confié à vous c'est un peu tout ça
c'est un peu du vécu c'est aussi le vécu
de certaines de mes amies ou de mes amis
garçons ou filles d'ailleurs tous les
gens qui ont rencontré c'est vraiment un
chagrin d'amour
en fait ça parle aussi du deuil delà du
fait d' accepter d'avoir perdu quelqu'un
et voilà bien sûr et virginie aussi à
lui ce genre d'expérience tous gens
autour de moi donc
mais j'ai recueilli un peu les les
confidences d'amis et puis et puis j'ai
observé moi même ce que faisait le
chagrin au moment je le vivais c'était
intéressant de pouvoir se détacher un
peu de mes émotions et de prendre du
recul en disant tiens je place par cette
phase là donc ça aussi c'est intéressant
à mettre dans la pièce et donc c'était
ça m'a aidée aussi
c'est peut être aussi donner de l'espoir
à ceux qui vivent actuellement un
chagrin parce qu'on s'en sort toujours
ça peut être long mais on s'en sort
toutefois s'en sort souvent et ça donne
beaucoup d'espoir de toute façon les
gens qui viennent alors ils sont émus
oui il ya des moments émouvants et rit
beaucoup et c'est beaucoup de gens
viennent me parler après parce que moi
j'aime beaucoup dire au revoir aux gens
à la sortie je faisais comme j'ai
beaucoup fait de jeunes publics aussi je
l'étais chanteuse enfin je suis toujours
chanteuse pour enfants et j'adore d'iran
voir aussi à la fin et je me suis dit
tiens mais avec les grands c'est pareil
c'est sympa de dire au revoir aux gens
et puis on a leur réaction comme ça à
chaud ce qu'ils ressentent et il ne le
cache pas quand il vous dit gentiment
mais la première impression qui ressort
avec le public c'est ça me fait du bien
de l'euro ils comptent peut-être que je
suis pas tout seul
nous sommes l'un de gens qui me disent
et beaucoup de gens qui nous disent
merci
il ya beaucoup de gens qui me disent on
le vit en ce moment près des gens qui se
laissent un peu plus aller à la
confidence ou qui nous attendent à la
fin dix ans et moins chiant plane
d'envoyer des gens qui pleurent en face
et c'est formidable c'est génial c'est
un vrai partage et puis effectivement je
pense qu'il vaut mieux quand ils sentent
que mentir en train peut s'expliquer
sans doute le succès de la pièce que
vous l'avez présente en 2017
le festival off avignon et une tournée
aujourd'hui
oui on a eu beaucoup de chance parce que
c'est une pièce qu'on a écrites
finalement il ya deux ans seulement on a
eu la chance de jouer
lyon d'abord où buffon ensuite on a en a
joué sept mois au théâtre la bruyère à
paris
c'est un très joli théâtre voilà et
ensuite nous commençons cette tournée
nous refaisons avignon l'été prochain
est ce que vous vous nourrissez aussi
peut-être des témoignages de vos
spectateurs pour modifier le spectacle
tout ça ça reste mais la hausse du début
ça ne sent pas les témoignages des
spectateurs qui font que le spectacle
change ce sont les idées qui nous arrive
alors que nous où il ya peu d'impro en
général dans ce que je fais moi j'aime
bien que les choses soient très carré
c'est justement parce qu elles sont
carrées que j'ai la liberté après deux
demi heure on en jouir mais mais il
arrive qu'on trouve des choses aussi en
jouant et y ce qui est merveilleux avec
le théâtre c'est que on recommence
chaque soirée que c'est tout le temps
c'est un renouveau permanent donc on
peut tester des nouvelles choses on peut
en enlever on peut en remettre le
spectacle est aujourd'hui n'est enfin si
palm c'est pas très différent non plus
mais c'est quand même plus du tout le
même que celui qu'on a monté il ya deux
ans on a rajouté des trucs on a trouvé
des complicités des fois on a fait d une
bourde une bêtise audiard mais c'était
génial en fait faut le garder
bon voila et ses incessants ça peut
durer des années mais il ya des pièces
que j'ai joué cinq ans et jusqu'à la
dernière s'était jamais la même vous
souhaitez que ça je voudrais qu'on
termine alors on a nommé william
mesguich qui jouent tous les rôles
notamment celui de votre ex-mari médias
aussi chaque des arts puncheurs
j'espère que j'ai bien prononcé à
starlette chèvrerie qui joue le chagrin
alors lui a remis lui mais c'était le
chagrin carnets mais moi j'ai vu cet
homme ans déjà j'ai trouvé cet homme
merveilleux parce que d'abord il est
très beau mais surtout c'est un comédien
absolument remarquable il est capable de
faire passer toutes les émotions il est
terrifiant il est drôle il est fou il
est sympathique il est affreux il a tout
bon lui et je les ai vus jouer dans une
pièce s'appelait la vie bien qu'elle
soit courte qui était avignon en même
temps que la mienne
dallas y ait moins que je jouais ya déjà
trois ans j'ai trouvé ce comédien
merveilleux g et j'avais déjà l'idée du
chagrin j'avais pas encore écrite cette
pièce mais je me disais tiens ça c'est
intéressant d'écrire sur le chagrin
j'ai vu ce garçon génial ou alors c'est
lui qu'ils ne font que là c'est mon
chagrin
je n'ai attendu à la sortie jeudi vous
êtes mon chagrin et donc il sait révéler
parfait pour la pièce vraiment un
formidable comédien mais ailleurs les 2
william aussi c'est un feu d'artifice
williams est un feu d'artifice pour s'en
rendre compte
rien de plus simple le théâtre espace
coluche de plaisir le 9 février pour
prochain c'est pour chagrin pour soi
sophie forte
merci beaucoup merci merci à vous merci
dépoussiérer le latin et le grec
questionner leur héritage leur
transmission à versailles le week-end
dernier se tenait la toute première
édition d'un festival entièrement dédié
aux lampes classiques et aux chinois
deux jours de rencontres et d'échangés
avec parfois des influences magique
regarder un langage de sorciers qui
emprunte au latin indiqué rawlings a
parsemé ses ouvrages de référence
d'antiques des emprunts qui ont donné
envie à la romancière blandine le callet
d'en faire un ouvrage sur une idée
soufflée par ces étudiants et déjà il ya
beaucoup de noms de professeur qui font
directement référence à des à des dieux
du panthéon grec ou romain le professeur
mcgonagall s'appelle minerva séminaire
va athéna la déesse de la sagesse est
aussi une déesse guerrière et lorsqu est
intéressant évidemment c'est que lennon
s'il s'agit pas simplement de deux
d'emprunter des noms c'est que la
personnalité des personnages qui les
portes sont aussi en accord avec les
dieux leurs homonymes antique une
démarche de vulgarisation qui
s'inscrivait dans le premier festival
des langues classiques organisé par la
ville de versailles
au coeur de cette édition la
transmission des racines pour comprendre
sa culture versailles son château cette
ville est une ville qui s'est construit
conçu dans le dans une logique de
référence à l'antique 1 le
une suffit de se promener dans les
jardins du château de versailles pour
voir ses statuts qui sont pour beaucoup
d'entre elles des copies identiques le
néoclassicisme est né à la cour une
vingtaine de rendez vous animés par des
chercheurs des historiens et des
romanciers pour dépoussiérer l'image des
langues
ouais j'aime bien la lithologie
oui ça permet justement de faire
vraiment le lien entre aujourd'hui et
les langues anciennes et montrer que ça
sert encore aujourd'hui et que c'est
important la culture antique
encore aujourd'hui le festival a attiré
près de 2000 passionnés les
organisateurs réfléchissent déjà à la
seconde édition des comptes et des
classiques les 10e rencontres théâtrales
ont débuté le 1er février dernier à buc
mais amoureux de théâtre pas
d'inquiétude il y encore quatre
rendez-vous aviv au théâtre des arcades
à l'insep tamini vous êtes responsable
du pôle culture de la ville
lanson et maguette marguerite chaîne
vous êtes la directrice artistique de la
compagnie 13 minutes et qui sera sur
scène le 8 février
bonsoir bonsoir alors tout d'abord je me
tente bien vous en sata mini ces
rencontres théâtrales ce sont des
moments pour petits et grands petits
grands cons ça se fasse tous les âges de
7 à 107 ans donc voilà l'idée c'est de
réunir toutes les générations autour
d'un festival qui va du classique au
contemporain avec l'idée de beaucoup
d'idées ça rencontrer les gens
envoyez des émotions les rencontres
intergénérationnelles des grands parents
qui viennent avec leurs petits-enfants
les parents avec leurs enfants etc
donc voilà vraiment favorisé cette ce
moment de rencontres et d'émotions et
des changes d'où une certaine
programmation très excessifs admis il ya
des classiques bien sûr vous avez aussi
beaucoup de comptes notamment dans cette
deuxième partie oui alors nous avons
quand même voulu d'abord je tiens à
souligner que c'est la dixième édition
dix ans pour nous c'est une date
importante
c'est un festival qu'on essaye de
développer tout le long tout le long des
années et l'idée c'est aussi de lui
donner du sens de la matière et c'est
vrai qu'on voudrait quand même que le
jeune public puisse trouver sa place
donc on a proposé une date à mercredi
avec les contes de perrault et l'idée
c'est aussi d'amener le jeune public à
s'intéresser au théâtre parce qu'on voit
qu'on a du mal quand même à le mobiliser
donc les contes de perrault seront
proposés par la compagnie a l'air de
rien le les compagnies quand on regarde
quand on creuse un peu elles sont du
territoire oui oui ça c'est important
pour nous parce qu en fait au delà du
festival lui-même qui cherche quand même
à investir
voilà dans dans le comment dire dans le
l'idée c'est aussi de faire venir des
compagnies du territoire on a quand même
un territoire qui est important on a
beaucoup beaucoup de talent et on a pris
en tout cas le pari de dire
de monter un festival de qualité avec
des compagnies qui en veulent et qu'on a
envie aussi de porter nous avons créé
d'ailleurs un logo qui s'appelle made in
big et l'idée c'était aussi de de
vraiment porter des talents et c'est le
cas d'une compagnie conte à l'attrait
azimuts et qui est donc une compagnie du
coin et qui nous a déjà fait un projet
qui était magnifique et là l'idée c'est
aussi de vraiment de de fédérer tout le
monde autour de ce projet là et de faire
découvrir donc c'est aussi une démarche
ce n'est pas simplement une
programmation l'idée c'est vraiment
d'amener les gens à suivre un projet à
le vivre de bout en bout et deux et
peut-être même de se dire j'y suis pour
quelque chose donner des avis donc ça
c'était important pour nous justement
marie le tchèque vous a présenté un t1
un festival comme ça des rencontres
c'est important pour une compagnie comme
la voix de ce que vous êtes du coin
la compagnie oui tout à fait bien sûr
que c'est important on va tout à fait
surtout que pour nous notamment cette
année c'est là l'opportunité de faire
notre première pour ce spectacle de la
belle et la bête qui
du coup qui a été créé à buc on a été
accueillis en résidence au théâtre des
arcades un soutien logistique un soutien
créatifs comme ça s'est passé ou un
soutien un soutient la création avec la
mise à disposition du théâtre le
soutient évidemment de des élus de la
ville d'années ça et donc ça nous ça
nous permet aujourd'hui de voilà
d'arriver à cette première étape qui est
la sortie de création et de se
confronter à un public à des regards des
premiers échanges en fait alors sa
création c'est la belle et la bête vous
l'avait nommé ou la co produisent et
avec la compagnie l'air de rien qui elle
se faire de ma part et versaillaise très
une libre adaptation
on n'est pas dans le roman de jeanne
marie leprince de beaumont alors presque
on est parti on est partis du compte on
est partis du texte déjà de marie la
prince de beaumont qui qui vraiment on
dit les mots de jeanne marie leprince de
beaumont
mais notre envie c'est évidemment de
l'emmener ailleurs d'en faire autre
chose de faire de ce conte qui est connu
de tout le monde voilà quelque chose
d'assez nous ferons plus voilà
exactement donc ce n'est pas du disney
mais on voulait en faire quelque chose
autour de l'idée de la rencontre
c'est surtout ça qui nous a touchés
l'idée de la rencontre de la beauté
aussi de cette rencontre
au delà des apparences de du regard
qu'on a sur soi qu'on porte sur l'autre
vous voulez parler de sensualité aussi
c'est entre eux pour ça qu'on a ajouté
une partie chorégraphique qu'on dit que
c'est un conte chorégraphique parce que
la danse il ya beaucoup de place danse
contemporaine et hip hop ses dauphins
voilà c'est ça c'est aussi la rencontre
de ces deux univers là parce que donc
christophe ouest et un autre interprète
vient du coût du milieu hip hop et moi
même de la danse contemporaine et puis
évidemment avec le théâtre
avec la comédienne louise corps sol est
donc avec ce trio là
on refait vivre le conte est un lion lui
apporte une autre dimension il ya
plusieurs sens de lecture et c'est aussi
pour ça qu'on a voulu en faire un
spectacle familial qui parle vraiment à
tout le monde avec une envie à la base
de parler aux adolescents aussi c'est
pour ça qu'on avait choisi
l'idée du comté puis est vrai le choix
de la belle et la bête j'en oublie c'est
un public qui va pas laisser ça mon
théâtre souvent les adolescents faut les
faire faut les pousser c'est ça aussi
qui vous intéressent à buc des
compagnies qui proposent des projets
pour ouvrir la culture à tout le monde
il était il était important pour nous
aussi la notion de résidence
parce qu'une résidence cetc suivre un
projet du début jusqu'à la fin ses deux
d'encourager une troupe c'est de venir
c'est de découvrir cette pouvoir parler
du projet je veux dire le projet en
lui-même là sont l'aboutissement n'est
que la cerise sur le gâteau et donc ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on aimerait
pouvoir développer parce qu'on voit que
ça a un impact sur le jeune public qui
aujourd'hui malheureusement fin
aujourd'hui ou même enfin je veux dire
la très quand même pour le théâtre est
assez faible
et alors qu'on y vit des émotions
extraordinaires mais c'est des petites
graines qu'on voudrait se met justement
pour qu'après parce que c'est vrai que
aller au théâtre avec son grand-père sa
grand mère c'est parfois c'est c'est un
souvenir inouïe et ça permet quand même
de grandir et d'ouvrir son esprit et on
encourage vraiment le jeune public à
venir donc on essaie aussi de programmer
des pièces qui sont étudiées dans les
collèges et les lycées
c'est aussi une manière de les appeler
vers nous alors on est un peu pris par
le temps il y à un spectacle qu'on ne
pourra pas nommé mais qu'on a vu les
images en spectacle très étonnant alors
c'est un peu pour les plus jeunes aussi
avec du sable lorraine bihorel qui fait
des choses absolument extraordinaire et
ses vins et de sable magnifique c'est
c'est vraiment je j'invite les gens à
venir c'est un voyage dans le temps
c'est une pause et d'une poésie
extraordinaire c'est voilà il ya juste
on est là le la beauté du geste la
beauté de du détail
et puis juste voyager dans le temps
c'est vraiment un super spectacle et
j'invite tout le monde
le voir merci à tous les deux d'être
venu en place oui le temps file toujours
très vite alors pour ne rien rater de
ces rencontres théâtrales le site de la
commune s'affiche en bas de l'écran un
autre musique à présent on débute avec
du jazz en faisant un bond dans le temps
le hollywood orchestra emmène le public
dans le répertoire des années 50-60 de
la côte ouest
la formation musicale était sur la scène
du théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
de week-end dernier regarder
[Musique]
une grande formation à l'image des
années 50-60 le hollywood orchestra vous
fait traverser l'atlantique à l'époque
des studios d'hollywood et des grandes
maisons de disques ou forme de démesure
ça c'est certain
c'est à dire que des mesures par là par
là l'importance du projet de nombre de
musiciens à prouver le caractère va
marquer strahl et puis
plus spécifiquement par rapport aux
arrangeur un goût du détail et de la
discrétion aussi qui est vraiment
particulier c'est un arrangeur qui
écrivent pour accompagner les chanteurs
des chanteuses la plupart du temps et
qui réussit à donner à la fois un
caractère important aux morceaux qu'ils
écrivaient tout en restant très discret
un rendre hommage aux arrangeur les
musiciens qui créé un orchestre souvent
dans l'ombre pour l'occasion les
quatorze musiciens de l'homme laddh big
band se transforme pour être 39 sur
scène accompagné de chanteurs la musique
elle est vivante si ça du coup le mettre
dans la m dans un contexte festif c'est
aussi je trouve la romieu vivante et la
faire sortir des musées si la pour le
muc arkestra l'aspect festif il est
toujours là il est important pour nous
et une démesure à l'américaine qui fait
du jazz une fête lors qu'être redevient
l'homme laddh big band 7 mars prochain à
doué pour un hommage à donnery mal
[Musique]
le
on accueille un nouvel invité joachim
kitoko membres du groupe el des quatre
qui se produit ce vendredi à la batterie
un groupe tour et sans toit sans merci
de l'invitation
ouais exactement ld4 c'est un groupe qui
s'est formé en fin 2007 on a sorti notre
premier clip ans en juin 2018
le clip qui a bien marché là l'histoire
suit son cours
qu'est ce qui vous a motivé à vous
former en groupe parce que j'ai cru
comprendre que la musique était avant
tout un divertissement
le groupe initialement c'est un groupe
de copains je pensais retrouver sur snap
on a formé un groupe et on a décidé de
tout les jours quand on se rencontre on
fait de la musique on fait des sur des
mélodies et à un jour on a fait une
vidéo qui a bien pris qu'un quart buzz
et on va dire on a répondu à la demande
tout simplement
et justement cette vidéo c'est à la
barre wales
il ya sept mois vous la mettez sur
youtube on est aujourd'hui à 170 mille
vue c'est ça qui vous a motivé aussi qui
vous a poussé à proposer d'autres choses
ouais ça a participé parce qu'on a vu
qu'il y avait un emprunt engouement
autour de autour de nous on a fait
plusieurs vidéos sur instagram snav
tchad
il ya eu des partages des artistes on va
dire un peu plus un peu plus connu une
carrière c'est ça qui nous ont donné un
petit peu de force on va dire et ça nous
a donné envie de continuer on voit qu'on
a un vrai soutien un vrai un vrai public
sur le bassin de 50 ans surtout et c'est
ça qui nous donne la force tous les
jours dans nos studios de
de sortir de nouvelles choses vous savez
ce qui plaît le sont les paroles la
jeunesse c'est tout à cg ce qui plaît je
pense que c'est les mélodies c'est les
sonorités on peut africaine qui c'est
simple ça rend dans la tête c'est on va
écouter la musique qui une fois on va là
commence à la chanter toute la journée
et ça rentre dans la tête
donc ça c'est du bourrage de crâne a
fait et ses sonorités africaines elles
vous vienne douze de vos familles vos
vous entourage ce sont des goûts
personnels
ouais ça vient du quotidien depuis tout
petit on a baigné dans la musique nous
plus congolaise on a baigné dans la
musique congolaise ça veut dire que
depuis tout petit on n'est pas là et on
est on est que tout le temps d on entend
tout le temps des nouveaux sons des
guitares des instruments qu'on connaît
même pas débriefé avec des des canettes
et après ça nous donne l'inspiration
avancé qu'il mais je vous propose qu'on
écoute on extrait potosi
[Musique]
ces fonds
tous les pays
les ateliers
alors ce vendredi c'est votre premier
concert dans un cadre professionnel vous
fait la première partie est ce que vous
êtes prêts est-ce qu'on est très heureux
parce qu'on est prêt passons on prend
les choses avec du recul
donc on sera comme d'habitude entre nous
entre copains donc ça veut dire que
malgré cet aspect plus professionnel on
va rester dans ce qu'on sait faire
donc on va rester naturel on va ambiance
et public comme d'habitude on va à
barres et on va continuer ce qu'on sait
faire de mieux
est-ce que ça va être aussi l'occasion
d'échangés que les professionnels qui
seront là parce qu'il y en a qui passent
après vous sur scène c'est clair qu'il
faut le prendre aussi comme une
opportunité de d'échanger avec des
professionnels de rencontrer de
nouvelles personnes de créer des
contacts aussi je pense que c'est une
bonne opportunité
ce genre de scène vous avez soutien de
la ville dans vos créations vous êtes
super par la batterie ou le phare
jeunesse ouais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
on a réussi à avoir le soutien de la
ville de guyancourt c'est à dire que
nous initialement quand on a nos
inspirations la première mélodie elle
vient personnellement quand on est chez
nous mais après dans la conception de la
musique on peut on a la chance d'avoir
le phare jeunesse à disposition qui me
retient un studio dans ses locaux
c'est à dire qu'on va travailler les
maquettes au phare jeunesse dans le
studio et puis ce qui nous permet
d'aller au studio directement aidé
finaliser son merci beaucoup
joachim je le rappelle vous faites est
un membre de l des quatre notre groupe
sera sur la scène de la batterie à
guyancourt ce vendredi 8 février et on
passe maintenant à notre page agenda
[Musique]
à la merise de trappes suivez la quête
de donkey shot le héros de cervantès
brave personnages marionnettes et objets
enchanteur un spectacle à voir dès 14
ans regarder
[Musique]
et
oh
[Applaudissements]
en ce mois de février les concerts
reprennent pour les amis de l'orgue de
coignières ce dimanche 10 février vous
pourrez écouter un duo trompette et
orgue un jeu d'écriture pour les moins
de 20 ans le réseau fil des pages vous
lance ce défi de réaliser des poèmes des
nouvelles des fictions autour d'une
liste de 10 mo cinq catégories sont
ouvertes et la remise des preuves des
prix aura lieu le samedi 25 mai la ville
de guyancourt recherche de nouveaux
talents le concours d'arts visuels
présente chaque année une sélection
d'oeuvres toutes techniques confondues
si vous souhaitez exposer vos créations
vous avez jusqu'au 10 mars pour vous
inscrire c'est la fin de cette culture
mercier de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve mardi prochain
[Musique]